bismillah hamdulillah psalm alaikum
peace be with you I'm Eddie your host
you're watching the dicho thank you for
tuning in we have a special guest in the
D show studio and for those that are
tuning in for the first time for second
time third time or you're with us all
the time we always have some exciting
topics and today we're going to be
really reflecting upon thinking really
about something more serious some of you
might have just you know flipped the
channels and you were watching Justin
Bieber and he's breaking down you know
you're part of the Bieber team and you
just you know getting fed up you it's
not bringing satisfaction to the heart
mind body and soul so people are looking
for purpose what's the purpose of life
and we're going to be really tackling
this topic and helping you develop a
better understanding and then at the end
you can decide if you want to really
continue to be a Berber Bieber fan or
whoever else is out there that's filling
your mind and the way that you're
intoxicating yourself with things that
really have no benefit or you can
benefit from the things that we're going
to say on this week's show and take it
implement it live with it and you can
have that peace that you've been looking
for we'll be right back with our special
guests talking about purpose purpose of
life here in the D she'll be right back
[Music]
this is the this is the thing you know
this is the thesis the theme is the name
you know this is the key with you how
are you sir how's it going your mom's so
hey Webb how are you thank you for being
with us on a Dean show great to be here
it's a pleasure
how have you been everything is good
everything is wonderful everything's
good in the hood as they say I think so
I don't mean to pick on nobody we want
the best for all of mankind and we want
the best for wasn't in Justin Bieber
right the reason I mention it is because
people really a lot of days you'll see
like right now we're showing a clip
[Applause]
these women they're going hysterical
they're crying they're pulling their
hairs out and even what happened they
someone died
no no one died but people just really
they've taken him as summer pull their
house for Justin Bieber yeah they really
you know and he's on a break down and
stuff so you know he's breaking down
he's breaking down we see a picture of
him here in the court right now he's got
arrested for DWI DUI thoughts yeah so
important we want we want an ADIZ shows
about helping people really live beyond
just you know satisfying the flesh and
the desires so you know how would you if
tomorrow you you I don't know you're at
a restaurant maybe you had a meeting
with Justin Beaver he came into your
community center how would you open up a
dialog to really talk about purpose
purpose of life with this young man well
that's very interesting first of all
it's great to be on your show
thank you you're doing a wonderful job
and you know me a lot continue to bless
Tommy thank you in shows and I'll just
had a baby boy mashallah so everybody
out there I think people don't realize
what humans yeah so may Allah bless your
son
I mean bacon and and make him someone
who lives a purpose I mean Driven Life
and the right purpose um you know it's
been a while man so it's good that we're
back together it's like the Muslim kid
and play yeah so uh you know that's
interesting because my own daughter um
you know one day about four years ago I
came home and she had purple on purple
he'd you have and everything and I and
this was in Egypt and she said I'm a
belieber I'm a believer hmm right so she
was in the fan of Justin Bieber and I
actually said to her why do you like him
what about and she went to an Islamic
school and everything so um I actually
sat down and kind of listened to some of
the songs with her mm-hmm and just asked
her do you think this is appropriate or
not and she said no right sir there was
one song he had about pray was pretty
nice about dua
but overall was just kind of you know
bubblegum music yeah I say but I think I
was very similar to Justin Bieber in the
sense of course I wasn't famous but when
I was young I made three records hip hop
albums listen to the names of these
groups ready
yeah please John Cole
cane crew yeah the cocaine crew yeah a
really wonderful name isn't it well ii
was mafia-style
and the third group ID Jayden produced
with him was called aka salt there's a
picture of me on my facebook wall when I
was young and out there and and I was
friends with a group called Color Me
badd if you remember those guys yeah
there's a boy that's a boy band right
there like a you know kind of a man man
man bared a little bit after the boy
band off they were okay yeah even
somewhat of somewhat of a boy band and I
was headed in that trajectory and really
into music had a great love for music
and was starting to go out on the road
with people and you know I was DJing
clubs when I was young and I would maybe
ask him what I asked myself I saw a guy
get shot when I was 17 he got his chest
blown out and that kind of hit me like
you know no matter how shiny this world
is no matter how beautiful this world is
it's the greatest lie ever told and the
lie is that we believe that this world
is going to last forever right that's
the lie that I'm talking about and the
Khurana says well my end ilahe back you
know what's with God lasts so I really
had kind of a breakdown even though I
had a lot of external pleasure as far as
the typical young lifestyle smoking
copious amounts of weed clubbing girls I
was I had a record out I was a sophomore
in high school
wow so arrogant very arrogant and and
full of myself and then seeing someone
die and then I had a Muslim friend named
Darrell who also is dead may Allah have
mercy on him who really there were
events life is a teacher in the number
of friends and they made me really think
about how these things are not going to
last so I think that might be my
conversation with JB you know we pray
for him we should pray for these people
man they're the crater guides them right
yeah right yeah not just you know dis
demand make fun
it's hard and and then try to ask him to
help me think about what life means to
him instead of just telling him what
life is yeah and it may be building kind
of a conversation we said no hold on you
are like a shared conversation between
the two of us that maybe will direct us
to understanding the real meaning of
life is to live beyond this life why do
you why do you think look the person
will have money they'll have Fame
they'll have all the delights of this
life but obviously you see like when
they arrested him he was on and some
prescription pills like like a xanax or
something like that I don't know exactly
what it's called but you see a lot of
the celebrities they're on
antidepressants they're on some sort of
pills some volumes they're turned into
drugs I mean people think okay if I
achieve this that's it I'm happy but
we're seeing the opposite yeah I don't I
don't think it's just celebrities I have
a television show um that I do in
Malaysia and I film sometimes you know
39 episodes in seven days mm-hmm 39
episodes in seven days and I was telling
you a friend of mine the second season
of that show called reflections it's
hard man I mean says it's a very
physically draining type of job so I can
only imagine what real celebrities go
through in the sense of that's that's
the word and I said to my friend you
know if I didn't have Salah and Iman I
probably smoking weed dude just to deal
with the the pressure and the pain kind
of to put yourself through and then you
go outside and Malaysia people take my
picture or they stop me it happens to
you here I'm sure and it's not
comparable to what those people are
going through but it's stressful so I
think when people don't have a
Venustiano because at the end of the day
right we know that all the money we have
is going to go we know that the shirt we
have is gonna fade we know the nice car
we have is gonna get scratched up so
we're actually banking on something that
we know is finite right it's not
infinite and that's where that sadness
comes in like I'm banking on things that
aren't gonna stay with me forever yeah
so I think redirecting people to as the
Prophet said you know what Labib said
the most intelligent thing anyone ever
said outside of the Quran of course he
said the most intelligent thing poets
ever said was that there's no life
except the life of the here
that's what does it cuz obviously this
life is gonna end sooner or later yeah
that I hope you this is short-term
investment short term yeah how about a
purpose it because uh okay
someone says look I'm sitting in my
basement I'm not harming nobody could
you get all sorts of answers to what the
purpose of life is so the purpose is
play he's like or whoever it is they're
sitting the basement playing xbox I'm
not harming nobody I'm smoking my weed I
even you know out of respect for my
parents I open up the window so it you
know doesn't bother them and that's it
I'm living my purpose I'm happy what
would you say to this person is that
really what purpose what the like
purpose of life is about people have a
right to declare their own happiness
uh-huh right but I think I would respond
to them and say you being happy with
those things you're not really
fulfilling your purpose mm-hmm it's like
when you train somebody and they want to
stay at a brown belt and you know that
they can go to be in a black belt or
someone stays in a white belt and you
know that they can move forward I think
sometimes one of the things that modern
society has reinforced is that human
beings aren't really that important but
although we have this human rights kind
of movement you know which seems to care
about human beings but in reality people
care about like people talk about the
economy like it's a person the economy
is sick right
iPads are beautiful but those are
adjectives that should never be used for
things that aren't human so so I would
talk to him about you know you've you've
adopted a set of values that hasn't
allowed you to really explore the
potential that you have as a human being
don't use your place there we're going
to be right back we got to go to break
they're signaling it we'll be right back
with more talking about purpose purpose
of life here on the Dean show I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone if Eliza
I'm not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if Allah is by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone if Allah is by
my side I am Not Afraid to stay
back here on the Dean show and I'm sorry
I had to cut you off we had to go to
break but please continue onward that's
all that needs to be said is that you
know when people are you know sitting
around and like Muslims man's Muslim sit
around and waste time the prophets lie
some said that nan attend Mahmoud or
FEMA concealment and that's right
there's two things that most people lose
out on one of them is time and and the
Prophet said in a beautiful hadith that
you know the feet of the sons of Adam of
people won't move on the day of judgment
until they're asked about four things
one of them is our time and that's why
you know that the the depletion of youth
people don't use their youth anymore and
and really people wasting time right
they ask you know people who commit
crime young people LA Times had boredom
right so I think people have forgotten
modern postmodern society has taken
meaning out of life man
because you know before the Industrial
Age people identified themselves
basically through God all over the world
through different traditions but there
was a purpose to life that transcended
this world when science became religion
right now science is telling people that
you really have no purpose you know you
came from an animal background and
you're going to die as an animal right
that creates a problematic reality
because number one people have no
purpose and we have no purpose we're
just going to waste our time and sit
around do very little with our time and
then thirdly it opens up to really like
a form of hedonism and we see that now
popular culture big time yeah yeah and
and religion is saying if science is the
language of the elements if grammar is
the language of words then Islam right
or religion is the language of the
spirit of the soul right so without that
soul man what do you have you have a
mannequin hmm and if you put the nicest
things on a mannequin what does it
matter you understand what I'm saying
yeah but if you have you know there's a
really really powerful documentary on
happiness and they went to this guy in
India who lives in a shack and he has
like a plastic bottle as his lamp like
the Sun goes through
it shines in the house and he was the
happiest in in his village they're like
why are you happy he's like I got this
new plastic bottle for a lamp he's like
I see my kids every day right I have
three walls instead of two in my house
he was crying out of happiness right
then you go to someone there was a man
they interviewed you used to be a former
Hollywood producer and he said the
moment I moved into the 63 room mansion
I became depressed because I had no one
to share it with mm-hmm so there's a
need spiritually to be connected to a
higher power right in our case it's
Allah subhana wa ta'ala we believe the
only true God right in our our language
or our vehicle for traveling to him is
what the Prophet taught us peace be upon
him and that helps us fill the meaning
of worship right that we believe our
purpose is worship so that's my next
question I was going to ask you you um
you it's - for question because met some
people okay the many of them not yet
Muslims
you mentioned prophet okay so please
when you explain to us what do you tell
about the pro you meant what property
you're talking about and second is what
is what is the purpose of life so we
asked it obviously it's not to sit in a
basement playing xbox maybe some people
say it's just to have a family raise
some kids or this is all you got so go
kick it hang out and just get all you
can money material things because you
will die trying exactly so what's the
purpose of life and you know and there's
nothing wrong like I'll play some Xbox
you know with my own my son or my
daughter battlefield he loves his game
called battlefield um but I think that
what happens is now Xbox is playing us
oh yeah you know we're not playing it's
playing us right it controls us so who
holds the joystick is it the game or the
person and and that's the danger now
when I was saying earlier of we're using
you know terms to describe and a lot of
objects that should really only be used
for people and and then look how people
are described so you could like you'd be
in a restaurant and people will be
eating like rare meat in here about a
massacre of human beings and just keep
eating you know but then they'll find
out that you know Apple is gonna release
iOS 8 and everybody stop
oh really think it's great on my phone
so what matters to us is very
frightening I'm not against technology I
just think that I don't want to be I
want to hold the joystick right I don't
want to be the one that's controlled by
the joystick if that makes sense yeah so
when we're talking about Islam I mean
our core tenets are belief in God angels
prophets books their judgment and
everything that happens for Damon is by
the will of God right we call a la
dadada when we're talking about the
Prophet and I think this is very
important point to make when we're
talking about Prophet Mohammed actually
were talking about all prophets because
the Prophet Muhammad VA equi Medina who
what he said in sahib o haughty that the
prophets are brothers in their religion
is one so when we're talking about
prophet muhammad we're talking about the
truth of every prophet that came before
him so he embodies the true teachings of
Jesus they're two true teachings of
Moses their truth so actually the
Prophet Muhammad and that's what makes
him the greatest prophet is a vessel
that contains Muhammad right I'm saying
this metaphorically and then all of the
prophets right so when we believe in
Prophet Muhammad we don't pick and
choose so we say the Prophet we're
talking about prophet muhammad
sallallahoalyhiwasallam peace be upon
him who we believe teaches us how to get
in the car turn it on and drive right
how to take that course to live that
purpose the purpose that he taught us is
to worship and we believe that if we
don't worship God will worship something
else and I've been there why I believe I
was worshipping something else
not necessarily another deity but drugs
clothes money fame myself being lazy and
and will continue maybe to talk about
how he expanded the concept of worship
not just to be in the mosque not just to
be in the church or the synagogue but
that how serving society right is one of
the ultimate acts of worship before we
go to break the brother says look look
I'm gonna get money or die trying like
you said what's your response we'll die
trying you know many people have done it
and and at the end of the day I mean if
that's what's gonna make you happy
you're responsible for yourself but I
think that that attitude is is is very
carnivorous what's the difference
between that person and like the tiger
who jumps in the jungle and just wants
to
eat everything and we see where the
attitude is getting us look at the
objectification of women on television
man just to get money what people will
do to themselves to get money right and
they know that that money you know now
the the big coin issue on showing is how
really fragile money is so what are you
chasing what's gonna matter mm-hmm and
we can talk about a beautiful hadith of
the Prophet about that maybe in the
future we're gonna come right back here
to wrap it up on the D show don't go
anywhere
it's like when did you think that you
had no purpose are you worthless the
value comes from purpose your purpose in
life is to worship the Creator not
worship your desires himself not worship
social pressure the celebrity culture
but worship the thing that's much higher
and transcendent above and beyond by
worshipping God and seeking his pleasure
you get pleased so you have double
pleasure back here on the Deen show
we're talking about meaningful
meaningful a very important topic
because like you mentioned earlier when
you're talking about we talking about
Justin Bieber deaf I mean that's a
reality you know and people die you saw
your friend die just kind of really woke
you up
so before we went to break you mentioned
a hadith saying of the last and final
messenger problem hum peace be upon can
you go ahead and will you ask me what I
would say to someone who their attitude
was yeah and unfortunately find this in
the Muslim community too right look how
look how young Muslims are forced to be
doctors and engineers mm-hm and the
driving edifice behind that is not that
anyone cares what they're going to be
happy doing it's this is what's gonna
get you paid honestly and and I don't
I'm sure if we ask most of the people in
our community who are doctors and
engineers I'm sure that's a great thing
to be a doctor most of the scholars
wanted to be doctors cuz they were
doctors of the hearts and household to
be doctors of the limbs yeah
but at the same time like people who
don't want to do that are forced to do
it and the edifice pushing at is money
right the factors that are pushing money
so I would remind them of a beautiful
hadith of our beloved prophet
and a hadith is something he said or did
or taught us is that yet about what made
2/3 atha three things follow the dead
person to the grave right his family
right his deeds and his money or her
family her deeds and her money
he said two of them leaving one of them
stays the two that leave are the money
and the family but as soon as the person
is put in that grave what stays are what
kind of imprint they left in this world
exactly yeah another thing I would tell
them there's a really beautiful story
that happened in the time of one of the
kings of you know ancient days in the
Muslim world mm-hmm a scholar Liz King
had a massive Kingdom so a scholar asked
him how valuable is your kingdom to you
how valuable is this just get richer
Drive died trying kind of yeah he said
you know it's it's the greatest kingdom
in the world it has no value no one has
seen a kingdom like this as of yet so he
said if I if I had you in the desert and
you had you were dying of thirst what
would you give me for a glass of water
is that I'd give you my kingdom
he said if I gave you that glass of
water and then you had to use the
restroom and I could block your urinary
tract right so you wouldn't be able to
use the restroom what would you give me
to let you use the restroom he said I'd
give you all my kingdom he said a
kingdom that you just said has no value
is only worth a glass of water and a
trip to the toilet amazing so that that
really helps us think about what we're
doing there's nothing wrong with being
rich you know I'd love to have money and
wealth but again am i holding the
controller is the controller holding me
and that's the danger of you know that
problem because the Prophet Muhammad
said that the best person is one who
Allah guides and they have means that
suffice them mmm right to have
sufficient means and you know eight of
the 10 promised paradise actionable by
shutting able Jenna were successful
businesspeople who funds you know NGOs
who funds efforts like this are the
wealthy right yeah but there's always
that danger of being controlled by it
yes and losing purpose before we cut out
we're almost out of time tell us because
we know in this program is really short
so we just want to give people a nice
taste but we know that without a doubt
Islam submission to the will of the
Creator not the creation been sent
throughout time through all the
messengers it's a way of life that
doesn't call you to anything that is
unnatural as a natural way to believe in
the Creator to do good to live a
righteous wholesome organic everyone's
going back to organic and it's based on
proof and evidence so for the person
that's - not yet Muslim who's out there
tuning in he's like so we have to say
what guidance what advice do you give
them because now there's all these other
religions all of these other ways and
now how can they be sure that what we're
talking about that Islam is surely the
way from the crater is not just some
made-up way of life from prophet
mohammed the most important and i think
that's a great question we should
welcome those questions right one of the
beautiful things about our religions we
welcome questions so i would say to that
person number one think about meaning
right what's meaningful to you having a
relationship directly with god not
through a person or through an authority
i think that was very powerful for me as
a young person that islam and you know
it was like immediately put me in touch
with a creator without anything in but
without any partners right yeah then
secondly is sustainability is this
religion sustainable is it something
that i can do on a regular is it
something is it asking me when i became
muslim you know almost pleasure
fraternity when i was in college and
instead i became muslim but I remember
as I was about to pledge that fraternity
which was Alpha last our friends were
alphas a lot of Muslims are alphas I
remember they were telling me like
you're gonna have to go through some
stuff that you're not gonna like in
order to pledge right yeah so after I
became Muslim I was like when is the
weird thing gonna happen
when is the weird thing that happened
that makes me like an official Muslim
what are they gonna put me on this set
or something yeah and it never happened
so it was very sustainable as an
American you know I became Muslim and I
didn't have to change too many things in
my life pray five times a day I wanted
to pray more than that fast once a year
I wanted to do that you know get to know
people beyond their ethnicities and
their languages like I love that coming
from Oklahoma the deep south right so I
would say that sustainability wise right
you can see that Islam has been as you
said gluten-free right this is man free
yeah and that's how you know it's from
God because it makes sense
touches your nature and allows you still
to be who you are if you're an actor
being actor if you're a rapper be a
rapper if you're you know jiu-jitsu God
be Jesus who guy but just tie the earth
to the heavens
right now they're separate but Islam
helps us to tie those things together
and have purpose thank you very much we
out of time thank you for being with me
the creator of the heavens that rewards
you thank you we started with peace we
have a piece we'll see little pieces
it's all about peace yeah and thank you
for sitting through the Deen show you've
got to really just reflect think and
ponder your life on this earth wasn't
just by chance accident you're not just
an accident that happened the Creator
created you with a goal in the purpose
but do you want to know the purpose and
we really strongly recommend that you
start off by asking beseeching the
Creator the one who created you your
maker for guidance they guide me guiding
me and if you're sincere and you really
want to know what the purpose of life
you as the one who created life he will
facilitate away it's that easy as that
simple so start asking earnestly and
continue to tune in every week to the
Deen show you can follow us on the
Twitter like us on Facebook and share
our programs with everyone you know so
more people can benefit and get to know
purpose the purpose of life we'll see
you next time God willing on the DS show
peace be with you